[Musique]
je suis désolé même le weekend
allô
oui
votre fils
son pronostic vital est engagé ça fait 6
mois que je fais tous les jours et
hôpital entrepôt on a vu tous les
spécialistes et puis
et puis rien
à réaliser avant la fin du monde parce
que ça va peut-être arriver plus vite
que prévu
tu crois vraiment que si tu réalises
tout ce qu'il y a longtemps il va se
réveiller je sais pas vraiment mais tu
trouves que je suis folle
mais ça me plaît
mon loup sur la caserne militaire
dédicacer mon skate par HDI à Tokyo
je suis au boulot
j'aurais tellement voulu partager tout
ça avec toi pourquoi tu m'en as jamais
parlées
[Musique]
tu vois le petit point là-bas
savoir qui est mon père et le rencontrer
au moins une fois de savoir que son fils
est dans le coma tu lui jappétique
vous voyez que je me bat pour rien non
c'est pas fini
[Musique]